ce matin je commence ma journée à 40 km
de l'usine la gare de Valognes une gare
propriété d'Areva c'est ici qu'arrive
les trains qui transporte les déchets
nucléaires en provenance des centrales
[Musique]
la SNCF achemine les colis radioactifs
sur les lignes normales les deux wagons
en question proviennent des centrales
EDF de Paluel et de Belleville
tout petit je rêvais d'aider les autres
sauvés secourir protéger finalement j'ai
changé de cap je suis journaliste et
j'ai décidé d'aller à la rencontre de
ces hommes et de ces femmes ordinaires
qui vivent des expériences hors du
commun et un côté assez excitant je
trouve aller approcher l'atome comme ça
d'aussi près
bon on va pas se faire des illusions
Areva ne va pas nous ouvrir toutes les
portes
probablement même qu'on ne verra rien du
vrai fonctionnement de la centrale nous
ont prévenu la visite sera très encadrée
parce que pour autant faut pas y aller
quand même franchir cette porte que les
autres peuvent pas franchir moi c'est ça
qui me fait avancer j'adore ça l'idée
d'aller là où les autres vont pas c'est
un peu le sens de notre métier je suis
en Normandie à 25 km de Cherbourg la
pointe de la Hague c'est assez
impressionnant c'est perdu au milieu de
nulle part c'est un temps normand
je vais passer plusieurs jours au cœur
de l'usine d'Areva qui recycle le
combustible nucléaire
ce site est unique au monde
[Musique]
au bout du bout de la presqu'île du
Cotentin perché sur son rocher
la voici
l'usine de retraitement des déchets
nucléaires de lag
c'est le général de Gaulle qui l'a voulu
au nom de l'indépendance nationale
ici à Riva retraite les combustibles de
toutes nos centrales nucléaires et ceux
de nos voisins européens et même du
Japon ou d'Australie
au cap de l'agde les courants et les
vents sont parmi les plus puissants
d'Europe idéal pour diluer d'éventuelles
rejets
le site s'étend sur 300 hectares
400 terrains de football
il est protégé par une double barrière
électrique
[Musique]
c'est aussi le plus gros employeur du
Nord Cotentin il fait travailler 5000
personnes
et trois d'entre elles seront mes guides
[Musique]
quand il ne se fait pas des frayeurs sur
son kitesurf Bruno supervise l'arrivée
du combustible usagé
[Musique]
il m'emmènera tout près de la zone rouge
là où les déchets sont déchiquetés
Christophe
la journée il manipule des bras
robotisés en zone contaminée le soir il
compte ses moutons avant d'aller dormir
Jean-Philippe quand il ne peint pas
l'usine dans son atelier il mesure
l'impact du site nucléaire sur
l'environnement local
avec eux je vais passer une semaine dans
un univers hors norme
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur le site de La
Hague merci on va commencer par un badge
je viens de pénétrer dans une usine sous
très haute surveillance
j'ai pas une pièce d'identité s'il vous
plaît
alors je vais procéder à la photo je
vous laisse regarder la caméra qui se
trouve juste en dessous s'il vous plaît
monsieur
le site est ultra sensible je serai donc
toujours accompagné par un moitié guide
moitié surveillant
donc ça c'est votre badge pour cette
semaine avec le nom prénom la photo pour
la reconnaissance par les agents de
sécurité et la date de validité du badge
merci beaucoup
un parcours fléché m'attend
première étape incontournable un cours
accéléré sur le traitement des déchets
nucléaires
ce qui arrive ici c'est ça
ce qui fait l'énergie d'une centrale
nucléaire
c'est ça c'est quoi ça à l'intérieur de
cette tube qu'on appelle aussi crayon
vous avez des pastilles des petites
céramiques de 8 mm de hauteur dans ses
pastilles vous avez de l'uranium qui a
été enrichi on va cisailler cet
assemblage récupérer la matière
valorisable à l'intérieur et séparer les
gaines c'est à dire les morceaux qu'on
aura découpés les grilles et les embouts
et on va le contacter
Areva affirme recycler 96% du
combustible qui entrent dans son usine
cette uranium après retraitement repart
comme carburant neuf dans les centrales
les 4% restants extrêmement radioactifs
seront vitrifiés et enfermés dans des
bons bonnes en inox
ça c'est le vrai déchet ça c'est le
déchet ultime voilà c'est un container
de déchets vitrifiés donc les 4% de
produits restants ce container là peut
ensuite être entreposé sur le long terme
vous n'avez plus de risques de
contamination puisque la contamination
est capturée emprisonnée à l'intérieur
de ce verre donc en attendant
tous les déchets nucléaires de
l'industrie nucléaire française sont
stockées ici à lag tout à fait ça quel
volume je me rends pas compte si vous
mettez tous les containers les uns à
côté des autres ça fait l'équivalent
d'un terrain de football
pour toute l'histoire du nucléaire
français c'est pas énorme d'où l'intérêt
du recyclage vous avez récupéré 96% de
cette matière là vous n'avez notre
reposage que de 4% et un jour peut-être
on les entreposera dans des cavernes
souterraines pour s'assurer d'en
entendre plus jamais parler d'eux tout à
fait
problème le site de stockage français de
bure dans l'Est de la France est très
loin d'être opérationnel mais ça c'est
une autre histoire
[Musique]
deuxième étape de mon parcours
initiatique une batterie de tests
médicaux obligatoires prise de sang
visite médicale et un truc barbare qui
n'appartient qu'au monde du nucléaire
une spectrométrie
[Musique]
bonjour c'est moi le client
a un degré de radioactivité naturelle un
test va déterminer mon taux le jour de
mon entrée et à la fin de mon séjour on
vérifiera que je n'ai pas été exposé à
une radiation accidentelle expliquez-moi
déjà
ce que je vais vous faire
rien du tout c'est vous qui allez tout
faire en fait à l'intérieur du de cette
colonne vous avez deux détecteurs qui
vont mesurer les rayonnements gamma qui
sortent de votre corps
voilà vous restez au milieu ça c'est la
colonne super c'est pas une radio vous
avez pas besoin de vous prêter contre il
faut que je reste 3 minutes comme ça 3
minutes
mais bon voilà c'est terminé
donc là c'est centré sur 1460 kg
électrovs c'est potassium 40 naturels
que vous avez dans le corps donc pour
vous c'est tout de suite là il y avait
5000 Becquerel de potassium 40 dans
votre corps donc voilà c'est normal
c'est tout à fait normal on est de 4 à
6000 betteraves suivant les chambres et
un travailleur du nucléaire il a la même
courbe que moi ou pas exactement la même
puisque en fait c'est vraiment
exceptionnel qu'on trouve quelque chose
et maintenant direction le vestiaire
ici tout le monde porte la même tenue la
tenue Areva blanche de la tête aux pieds
[Musique]
bon ben voilà
et bien non ça n'est pas encore fini
nous voilà en tenue universelle
il manque les accessoires indispensables
à ma panoplie de visiteurs les deux
immenses maintenant je vais vous donner
votre dosimétrie alors la deuxième tri
il y a deux deux symétries
réglementaires la deuxième tri passive
et la deuxième écrit opérationnelle
celle-là on l'appelle passif pourquoi
parce que vous n'avez pas pouvoir
mesurer la dose que vous avez pris il
faut le développer au laboratoire de
dosimétrie c'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle
une dosimétrie passive et là je vais
vous délivrer à 12 mètres de y mettre
donc une deuxième tri active celle-ci
une deuxième maîtrise qu'on appelle la
deuxième minuterie opérationnelle c'est
un dosimètre électronique qui permet de
lire la dose que vous prenez en temps
réel donc c'est ça ça si je dépasse la
dose ça se déclenche tout à fait tout à
fait on est pareil et ben on y va
[Musique]
Franck me donne les dernières
recommandations avant mon premier
contrôle dosimétrique
maintenant c'est bon vous pouvez rentrer
donc
cette fois ça y est j'entre vraiment
dans la machine je note au passage que
les couleurs des murs ont changé du bleu
au vert dans l'usine il y a un code
couleur 5 nuances classées par ordre de
dangerosité
bleu vert jaune orange et rouge
le rouge indique les zones interdites
aux humains
dans le couloir je remarque que les
portes sont plus difficiles à ouvrir
on garantir le confinement des matières
on a un système de dépression des
dépressions qui sont en cascades plus on
avance plus les dépression sont
importantes voilà donc entre deux zones
entre une zone de et une zone 3 on va
avoir du mal à commander à ouvrir la
porte à cause de la dépression
en cas d'accident la dépression sert à
retenir l'air contaminé à l'intérieur et
à éviter la dispersion
mon nouveau guide s'appelle Bruno il est
responsable de l'entrée du combustible
dans la chaîne de recyclage et Bruno et
le roi du kitesurf
[Musique]
les portes et les couloirs se succèdent
il n'y a plus de fenêtre aucun repère
jusqu'à cet étrange hublot
[Musique]
ce que je voulais voir c'est la première
fois de ma vie que je peux presque
toucher du combustible nucléaire
[Musique]
je suis dans une des deux salles de
réception des déchets envoyés par les
centrales le cœur névralgique de l'usine
c'est ici que commence la chaîne de
retraitement
je vois enfin de près les bars d'uranium
ce sont ces colonnes de métal qui
mesurent 4 mètres de haut et pèse 800 kg
donc ça là c'est une zone rouge oui
c'est une zone rouge on peut pas y
accéder qu'est-ce qui nous sépare on a
carrément à hublot et on a un mètre 30
qui nous sépare là d'ailleurs on devait
des techniciens pilotes à distance
depuis la salle de conduite les bars
d'uranium radioactives usagés la
procédure est lente et délicate
même depuis mon poste d'observation je
sens la tension qui règne lors de cette
manipulation
dans un premier temps l'élément
combustible est immergé dans un bassin
pour faire chuter sa température en un
quart d'heure il passe de 400 à 80
degrés puis l'assemblage ressort quand
il va être en position haute il va aller
chercher le numéro de l'élément
combustible chaque élément combustible a
un numéro voilà exactement carte
d'identité et c'est indispensable il
faut bien la lire c'est c'est primordial
et le pied et voilà on le voit le pied
le pied de l'élément combustible ah ça y
est il est en train de se centrer au
dessus du puits
[Musique]
va sur son panier final
ce combustible usagé va être stocké dans
la piscine pendant plusieurs années
donc voilà il est rentré dans son panier
pour quelques années trois trois cinq
ans trois cinq ans
[Musique]
en 2013 l'usine a retraité plus de 1100
tonnes de combustibles usagés en fait je
m'aperçois que des Français ont une très
faible idée de ce qu'est un combustible
nucléaire à quoi ça ressemble
dans quelles conditions on peut le
manipuler dans quelles conditions on
peut le retraiter dans voilà c'est
finalement la seule image qui me serait
venue spontanément c'est un truc avec
une pelle et
je sais pas j'en sais rien voilà je
savais pas que ça avait cette allure là
comme quoi ça avait un coup de venir
avant de quitter l'atelier je vérifie
mon taux d'irradiation et je découvre ce
qu'on appelle ici le fer à repasser je
vous laisse faire
un autre appareil d'accord
s'il y avait quelque chose qu'est-ce qui
sonnerait
contaminer
il sonnerait et il y a l'arme rouge
donc l'idée c'est de mettre les deux
pieds là-dessus donc ça ça contrôle les
pieds en fait c'est ça
[Musique]
non contaminé
OK
[Musique]
et je repasse en zone bleue
et profite d'une petite pause pour
parler avec Bruno
je suppose Bruno quand on travaille dans
le nucléaire qui a les amis les voisins
tout ça ça pose des questions ah ben en
général il demande est-ce que vous
prenez des doses donc ils savent déjà ce
que c'est de là on essaie de leur
expliquer quand en général on prend 0,1
millisevers qui est un film 0,1 mbz
c'est l'équivalent d'une une radio du
poumon mais j'imagine toi tu fais du
kitesurf c'est ça c'est ton activité de
loisirs là c'est extra professionnel
quand tu tombes sur un anti-nucléaire
comment ça se passe nucléaire en général
j'essaie de
lui comment dire de lui expliquer les
choses mais c'est pas facile il a ses
idées et ne démarre pas donc il y a pas
de communication et c'est là la
problématique c'est que comme il n'y a
pas de communication mais le dialogue
est rompu finalement c'est monologue
qu'est-ce que je fais bah viens voir ce
qu'on mange je suis sur l'eau voilà
tu vois on a égalité
merci en tout cas on trinque au café
évidemment il y a jamais d'alcool
interdit interdit strictement interdit
[Musique]
c'est mon deuxième jour à lag hier j'ai
vu entrer des déchets radioactifs
derrière une vitre de plus d'un mètre
d'épaisseur aujourd'hui je vais accéder
à la piscine dans laquelle sont stockées
les barres d'uranium
[Musique]
je vais approcher l'atome avec les
dégaineurs les hommes de la cellule
d'intervention en milieu radioactif ils
doivent effectuer un contrôle de routine
la vérification des filtres de la
piscine ils font ça tous les 15 jours
l'opération la consiste à nettoyer les
filtres qui permettent justement de
nettoyer l'eau de la piscine dans lequel
se trouvent les éléments combustibles ok
en fait les réacteurs qui viennent des
centrales dessus il y a des dépôts qui
sont sur les gaines des combustibles
usés que l'on met en piscine d'accord
donc il y a des impuretés qui sont dans
l'eau et c'est ce qu'on filtre sans
cesse
direction la piscine ou est stockée sous
l'eau le combustible nucléaire et ça
commence par l'enregistrement de mon
dosimètre
[Musique]
80 mètres de long 15 mètres de large le
bassin ressemble à une piscine olympique
on peut y stocker plusieurs centaines de
paniers contenant les assemblages
radioactifs qui vont refroidir lentement
pendant trois à cinq ans et je découvre
que l'eau est le meilleur rempart
naturel contre les irradiations
dans ces paniers il y a le combustible
nucléaire à retraités
autour
elle est dangereuse ou pas c'est une
autre c'est une autre qui n'est pas
dangereuse mais elle n'est pas
radioactive
elle est pas radioactive d'accord donc
au fond il y a pas de risque de
d'exposition
à une matière radioactive dans cet
enceinte là sauf si on va toucher les
les barres de combustibles et elles ont
a quoi combien il y a d'eau là en fait
de protection biologique
entre les combustibles et nous
pour effectuer le nettoyage des filtres
toute l'équipe doit se glisser dans la
tenue réglementaire en zone exposée
adresse code à ses contraignant ça
s'appelle mettre la ceinture et les
bretelles après avoir enfilé trois
paires de gants et mis une charlotte le
pantalon vinyle
je passe le haut en vinyle puis on me
glisse un masque à gaz là on va basculer
à l'arrière
ce dernier élément qui nous reste à
mettre c'est la
cagoule pour la présente comme ça et là
on va mettre la protection
c'est bon
donc vous êtes prêt pour faire
l'intervention
ces hommes doivent contrôler les filtres
disposés au fond de la piscine ces
filtres servent à nettoyer l'eau
déminéralisée en circuit fermé qui
refroidit le bassin ou sont stockés les
paniers de combustibles
avant de récupérer les tamis l'opérateur
ça rime à la rambarde avec un harnais de
sécurité
c'est une étude on peut pas avoir idée
c'est horrible
[Musique]
pour récupérer les filtres les méthodes
sont artisanales
un crochet de marins-pêcheur suffit pour
remonter le casier
dès que le filtre est sorti du bassin un
autre technicien contrôle son niveau de
radiation
[Musique]
tout élément qui sort de la piscine est
contrôlé d'un point de vue radiologique
donc on va vérifier la contamination et
pour l'instant il y en a où il y en a
pas il y en a où il y en a pas là
aucune contamination donc là j'ai
vérifié aussi la science des radiations
sur les paniers citrons il y en a pas
non plus rien du tout ok
deux heures plus tard les techniciens
rangent tout l'équipement utilisé les
objets connectés seront analysés
ultérieurement par le Centre avant
d'être traité comme des déchets
faiblement radioactifs
[Musique]
à mon tour de me livrer à un strip-tease
avant de passer au contrôle légère un
contrôle de plus
l'appareil vous prenez en main propre et
vous allez contrôler
toute la partie du masque
voilà tout doucement tout doucement on
se rapproche vous pouvez retirer votre
vêtements
[Musique]
quand on enlève ça fait son arc
avant de partir je sonde un des dégâts
sur le stress que peuvent ressentir leur
famille
[Musique]
ta femme elle
l'idée que tu sois si près de la matière
visible ça ça lui plaît ça lui fait peur
ça lui plaît ça lui fait pas peur non
plus bon après c'est vrai que elle
savent pas forcément ce qu'on fait en
détail c'est pas toujours évident à
expliquer
au cinéma à s'imaginer commencer
vraiment à l'intérieur quoi donc mais
non elle est pas inquiète par rapport à
ça donc merci
[Musique]
je quitte la piscine parce que j'ai
rendez-vous à l'autre bout de l'usine
avec les membres d'un service
extrêmement important lui aussi dans un
univers aussi sécurisé
[Musique]
branle-bas de combat chez les pompiers
un exercice incendie vient d'être
déclenché par surprise de la fumée
s'échappe d'une fenêtre
les pompiers de l'usine Delag disposent
des mêmes moyens qu'une ville de 30000
habitants
c'est bon fin de la manœuvre pour la
première partie on va faire Frédéric
ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
[Musique]
pompier ici ou à la
1998 depuis 98 vous êtes intervenu
vous êtes intervenus sur combien de feu
ici
j'ai pas fait
donc en fait on s'entraîne tous les
jours pour un truc qui arrive quasiment
ce qui fait la force du système c'est
que si on se dit bah il va rien se
passer qu'on s'entraîne pas le jour où
il va se passer quelque chose on sera
complètement la ramasse et quelque part
on protège nous aussi notre outil de
travail parce que c'est notre outil de
travail on préserve notre outil de
travail et vous protéger votre enfin
votre entreprise votre outil de travail
une bonne partie de la Normandie une
grosse partie de la France et une partie
de l'Europe quand même
quelque part ouais on a un tout petit
maillon de la chaîne mais il y a un
maillon qui casse toute la chaîne elle
est rompue donc quelque part nous il
faut qu'on soit et on s'entraîne pour ça
mais il y a pas de frustration à
s'entraîner 15 ans pour jamais
intervenir boulanger il fait des gâteaux
il mange pas tous les jours
[Musique]
n'empêche que les pompiers doivent quand
même s'entraîner tous les jours
[Musique]
au-delà de tout ce qu'on a déjà vu en
plus ils ont une gare à eux
bon reprenons
[Musique]
et tu sais toi si à un moment donné
c'est tout est radiant s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
pour moi c'est un théâtre ça les gens
qui s'habillent comme ça ce sont presque
comme des acteurs
ce matin je commence ma journée à 40 km
de l'usine la gare de Valognes une gare
propriété d'Areva
mon guide s'appelle Armelle elle est
responsable du terminal ferroviaire
c'est ici qu'arrive les trains qui
transportent les déchets nucléaires en
provenance des centrales
[Musique]
incroyable que au-delà de tout ce qu'on
a déjà vu en plus ils ont une gare à eux
quoi
c'est une guerre privée
ça fait 15 ans Carmel veille sur ses
convois
[Musique]
ça n'est pas forcément simple car
l'endroit est connu des anti-nucléaires
protester c'est arrivé effectivement je
vous le cache pas c'est arrivé ça jamais
été ultra violent
[Musique]
la SNCF achemine les colis radioactifs
sur les lignes normales les deux wagons
en question proviennent des centrales
EDF de Paluel et de Belleville
chaque sarcophage pèse 120 tonnes à
l'intérieur seulement 6 tonnes de
combustible
[Musique]
les sarcophages sont protégés des
regards indiscrets par un carénage blanc
appelé
[Musique]
les emballages et les colis ne sont
jamais visibles du public en cours de
transport les cadeaux piles ou pas de
rôle de sûreté ou de protection physique
ou quoi que ce soit ils sont juste là
ils dissimulent un peu ils évitent bien
sûr qui ait un accès direct du public au
colis et puis ouais ils ont ils nous ont
invité par le passé que c'est les
canopies compris quelques gets de
peinture plutôt que soit l'emballage
c'est particulier ou pas oui c'est
particulier qu'on est bon ça change les
notes déjà par le site du convoi
exceptionnel déjà par le poids donc il y
a plus d'attention à avoir au niveau de
la route après bon il y a la matière
aujourd'hui c'était Rick qui doit
piloter le convoi exceptionnel il
transporte des matières nucléaires
depuis 25 ans avant de partir il vérifie
attentivement l'état des 80 roues de la
remorque pour regarder les pneus
intérieurs on regarde un sarcophage de
120 tonnes tractées par un camion de 60
tonnes
est prête c'est prêt
ce sont 180 tonnes qui vont s'élancer
sur les routes du Cotentin escorté par
quatre motards
[Musique]
et c'est parti pour 90 minutes de
conduite sous haute tension à 30 km
heure de moyenne
[Musique]
chaque jour un convoi identique par de
la gare de Valognes pour rejoindre
l'usine à une quarantaine de kilomètres
[Musique]
après avoir quitté l'autoroute le convoi
s'engage sur une départementale le
chauffeur doit redoubler de vigilance
surtout lors de la traversée des petits
villages
une fois dans l'usine la remorque est
parquée dans un hall où le sarcophage
sera déchargé
[Musique]
les équipes de radioprotection entre en
piste il faut vérifier la parfaite
étanchéité du container
[Musique]
avant que nous on intervient de sur
l'emballage donc les gens contrôle c'est
l'emballage est conforme d'accord
quelque chose m'intrigue l'emballage est
extrêmement chaud
j'ai un truc à vous demander venez voir
il fait chaud là
les ailettes là c'est pour c'est des
élèves en cuivre qui servent à la
diffusion de la chaleur donc on
refroidissement une certaine manière
je contrôle s'il y a pas une de tes
réorient des ailettes je contrôle si les
vis sont bien en place
est-ce qu'il était tombé
les équipes passent l'enveloppe du
château au peigne fin à la recherche de
la moindre anomalie à l'intérieur les
fameux tubes d'uranium que j'ai
découvert le premier jour il faudra près
de 10 heures pour qu'ils entrent dans la
chaîne de recyclage
[Musique]
j'abandonne le château pour rejoindre
l'école des métiers bonjour
non enchanté
son personnel technique
ma visite commence par la découverte des
trois tenues d'intervention que doivent
revêtir les techniciens pour aller sur
les lieux à risques une sorte de petit
musée de la Mode nucléaire
beaucoup de machines utilisaient ici
sont des prototypes ces robots ont été
inventés sur place pour pénétrer en zone
rouge là où les hommes ne peuvent pas
aller
la manipulation de ces machines oblige
les techniciens à se former en
permanence et vous allez vous entraîner
pendant 5 ans oui enfin on va se
perfectionner au mieux pour pouvoir
réaliser les monter le monde on les
règles de l'art donc là on a le gros
robot on va dire et ici on a
d'accord donc celui-là qui est la
différence avec le groupe alors celui-ci
nous sert essentiellement à faire des
prises d'échantillons à les récupérer un
dépôt quelque part
pour envoyer ce dépôt dans un
laboratoire analyse
[Musique]
à l'école on forme aussi des télés
opérateurs ils interviennent en zone
rouge grâce à des bras articulés qu'il
manipulent à distance une sorte de
prolongement de leurs mains
pour vous faire une petite démonstration
et après vous essayez de reproduire donc
on va prendre cette petite bille
[Applaudissements]
et
on arrive vraiment à reproduire les
gestes de la main avec ces outils
si vous voulez bien essayer donc là je
vais juste la poignée et c'est ça qui
passe voilà mais faut tenir le bras pour
pouvoir faire le mouvement de la main
et ça n'est pas aussi simple à manipuler
quand joystick
bon reprenons marquer ce serait pas
normal que j'arrive à faire quelque
chose que vous maîtrisez depuis 30 ans
[Musique]
un peu comme dans les attractions de
fête foraine on gagne presque à tous les
coups
[Musique]
chaque matin Christophe nourrit ses
moutons avant d'aller travailler il est
élu opérateur chez AREVA mais il n'a pas
voulu lâcher la ferme qu'il a hérité de
ses parents ça peut avoir une s'échapper
c'est vrai que sur le site de lag
les bâtiments qu'on voit hors de terre
il y en a autant sous terre donc on
travaille souvent dans l'ombre et sous
terre et quand on sort on a envie de de
forcément de vous retrouver
j'ai bien compris que dans la région
l'usine donne du travail a beaucoup de
monde comme des milliers d'habitants du
coin Christophe en a bénéficié il y a 15
ans à la sortie du lycée agricole il a
frappé à la porte de l'usine aujourd'hui
il travaille sur un site névralgique
l'atelier de vitrification là où les
déchets ultimes sont fondus et coulaient
dans du verre
au troisième sous-sol de l'usine au cœur
de la chaîne de recyclage Christophe et
son coéquipier Raphaël vont réaliser une
opération très délicate derrière cette
vitre d'un mètre 30 d'épaisseur la zone
rouge seuls les machines peuvent y
rentrer je vais la prendre je vais la
prendre avec la corde
là ce qu'on est en train de faire on est
en train de réparer une une manchette
[Musique]
pour changer ce simple joint de
tuyauterie les télésopérateurs vont tout
de même mettre plus d'une heure
on peut intermédiaires d'accord celle-ci
on peut pas celle-là c'est trop zone 4
c'est interdit
et ce beau carreau de
plomb on voit bien
j'observe Christophe il semble
parfaitement à l'est dans cet univers
industriel lui le fils de paysan
normalement l'agriculteur
il est anti-nucléaire parce que non
pas du tout bien au contraire mais
personne n'en voulait cette usine
c'est vrai quelque part les Bretons
l'accepter et puis on peut en prendre un
autre que fier vraiment que fier
j'évite vu que ceux qui travaillent ici
ont une confiance aveugle dans leur
usine et ne sont jamais avares
d'arguments pour me convaincre on me dit
que les concepteurs de la Hague n'ont
pas choisi le cas par hasard que les
vents et les courants marins sont très
puissants et permettent de disperser
dans l'air et dans la mer les éventuels
rejets que la roche sur laquelle est
battie l'usine est très ancienne est
très stable ce qui mettrait l'usine à
l'abri des séismes et qu'à 180 mètres
d'altitude on ne craint pas les
tsunamisu
après toutes ces années de certitudes ok
ici c'est pas possible non
tu crois pas j'y crois pas
je crois que j'ai compris le cycle du
retraitement des combustibles mais que
deviennent les installations de cette
usine contaminée les centrales
nucléaires les machines c'est l'autre
métier d'Arena le démantèlement de cette
contaminé marcher d'avenir
la responsable c'est l'or elle me
conduit dans les vestiges de la première
usine une ancienne zone rouge qui date
de la fin des années 60 et dont la
décontamination est presque achevée
le but c'est de enlever toute trace de
radioactivité dans ce bâtiment et voir
circuler en civil sans sans les tenues
qu'on a aujourd'hui et
on garde le bâtiment où on le rase de
bâtiment à des fins de réutilisation
pour le futur
et c'est parti pour un nouveau dédale
sans oublier de pointer son dos y mettre
[Musique]
ce bâtiment a cessé son activité en 1998
depuis il a fallu vidanger les cuves
démonter toutes les installations et
stocker les déchets ça a été très long
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
16 ans plus tard il reste encore
quelques mètres carrés à décontaminer la
sous cette bulle de plastique
le chantier démantèlement donc
c'est un Airbus A380
chaque chantier de décontamination est
un projet unique le moindre geste est
anticipé surveillé et contrôlé plusieurs
fois rien n'est laissé au hasard et ça
peut durer entre 10 et 30 ans sous ses
tentes de travail
je voudrais comprendre qu'est-ce qui se
passe là-dessus sous ses bâches roses
[Musique]
l'air qui nous entoure
dans le sas n'est pas dans l'autre sens
exactement
et donc là l'opération qui a eu lieu
c'était une la découpe en quatre
morceaux de la trappe en fonte qui
faisait bouchon avec le silo donc voilà
donc ça c'est un exemple de disque dont
on s'est réveillé pour découper la
trappe
et ce qui craint plus que moi lui là où
non
d'air les respirables donc il respire
pas ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur tout à
fait il respire le réseau de l'air donc
respirable de l'usine d'accord
[Musique]
cette usine gigantesque il faudra bien
la démanteler un jour et trouver du
personnel motivé on trouve facilement
alors des du personnel pour faire un
travail comme ça parce que moi je me
mets à la place d'un gamin de 20 ans qui
ont dit il y a du job mais ça essaie
d'aller là avec cette tenue là on voudra
pas si si quand on est à la veille de
faire une manip enfin la manip qu'on
attend depuis plusieurs semaines
généralement les agences aussi très
contents
de se former sur ce type d'opération
ce sont déjà des gens qui ont une
certaine habitude qui ont une certaine
expérience
une fois de plus pas question d'échapper
au contrôle d'osymétrique
[Musique]
si à l'intérieur de l'usine tout est
sous contrôle Areva s'intéresse aussi à
ce qui se passe hors de ces murs autour
du site et le monsieur environnement de
musique c'est Jean-Philippe direction la
petite crique de Gourio et son port de
plaisance
pour aller là-bas et on va faire quoi
donc on va faire un prélèvement d'eau de
mer dans le port mais comme le porc est
à marée basse on va le faire de l'autre
côté du de la digue et jusqu'à ce qu'on
est suffisamment d'eau pour ramener
quelques litres
chaque matin Jean-Philippe effectue une
tournée de 3 à 4h dans les environs de
l'usine au gré de son périple il peut
rouler une cinquantaine de kilomètres
pour recueillir des échantillons pour le
laboratoire
il commence aujourd'hui par récupérer de
l'eau de mer
j'aurais dû faire pareil moi je suis
[Rires]
pas trop là ça va
et tu fais ça tous les jours ouais
voilà et tu sais toi si à un moment
donné
ce qu'on trouve là-dedans par habitude
par expérience en fait dans l'eau de mer
on trouve énormément de potassium 40 ça
et comme dans le corps humain en fait
d'accord c'est de la radioactivité
naturelle la mère est pleine de
potassium 40
le but de ces prélèvements vérifiez
l'impact de l'usine sur l'environnement
et donc sur la population
[Musique]
Jean-Philippe effectue ses prélèvements
dans l'eau mais aussi dans l'air sur les
animaux sur les végétaux et même dans le
beurre
le dernier échantillon de la journée
sera prélevé au pied de l'usine dans un
pâturage nous allons collecter un mètre
carré d'herbe choisi au hasard
fait quoi pour mettre ça j'ai un sac
allez merci
tous ces prélèvements sont ensuite
analysés dans l'usine pour vérifier
qu'il n'y a pas de contamination de
l'environnement un vaisseau spatial d'un
mètre carré
pendant longtemps le site a gardé secret
les résultats de ces analyses mais le
manque de communication a fini par lui
porter préjudice alors en 1999 pour
regagner la confiance de l'opinion
publique Areva a décidé de mettre les
résultats en ligne pour répondre à mes
questions c'est le chef de Jean-Philippe
le patron du laboratoire qui a été
désigné là encore le ton se veut très
rassurant qu'on essaie de prélever des
tracés exhaustifs sur tout ce qu'on va
trouver autour du site le but c'est de
vérifier si il y a ou pas des rejets
notre objectif c'est de vérifier
l'impact du site sur son environnement
et pas que l'impact nucléaire c'est
l'impact nucléaire et chimique et
chimique voilà parce qu'on fait aussi
des analyses en particulier sur nos
rejets on fait des Anaïs chimiques
d'accord il y a jamais
d'incident qui faut que pendant 24 48
heures on va trouver un peu plus de
radioactivité que d'habitude puis après
ça se dissout lorsqu'on a eu dans le
passé quelques événements je rappelle
d'abord que ces événements en fait sont
tous été déclarés lorsqu'on nous avons
eu ces événements et toujours en
capacité à vérifier l'impact de ces
événements sur l'environnement
ponctuellement et aujourd'hui nos
événements radiologiques dont un impact
extrêmement mineur sur le sur
l'environnement du centre et il date de
quand c'est le dernier événements je
prends un dernier événement c'était en
2001 par exemple nous avions eu un rejet
de rueilium au niveau de l'atelier de
vitrification et ce rejet de rutanium
avait été qualifié et l'impact est
extrêmement faible depuis rien de plus
rien rien de notable
la journée s'achève et je vais découvrir
que Jean-Philippe mon préleveur
d'échantillons mène une double vie quand
il tombe l'uniforme Areva c'est pour
revenir à ses premières amours la
peinture
mais même dans son atelier à des
kilomètres de La Hague l'usine n'est
jamais loin
[Musique]
qu'on veut pas un paysage qu'on veut pas
de la règle avec tout ce que ça
représente le côté majestueux là qu'on
est sur les devant le cap de la c'est
pas du vivre peindre la nature c'est pas
un devis tandis que peindre finalement
des bonhommes des formes des cheminées
c'est c'est très concret pourquoi parce
que une usine c'est quoi c'est des
architectures c'est des rythmes c'est
des couleurs c'est des formes
[Musique]
c'est une galerie d'art local qui lui a
proposé de peindre son usine sur des
cartons Areva
[Musique]
moi j'ai pu aborder l'usine en tant que
peintre c'est parce que je me sentais
bien on peut pas j'ai pas justement dans
ce que j'ai pu traduire dans l'usine
chercher à traduire une sensation de
risque ou pas du tout il faut bien voir
que les gens qui s'habillent dans le
nucléaire il s'habillent comme les
pompiers s'habillent pour tous les
risques il peut y avoir comme tous les
gens qui sont dans un domaine s'habille
avec les protections nécessaires voilà
pour moi c'est un théâtre ça les gens
qui s'habillent comme ça ce sont des ce
sont des presque comme des comme des
acteurs
disons les acteurs d'un film catastrophe
[Musique]
c'est la fin de mon séjour
je dois repasser par le centre médical
pour faire mes tests de sortie
voilà c'est
parti le médecin va comparer mon taux de
radioactivité avec celui du jour de mon
arrivée
alors
c'est parfait alors je vais vous montrer
avant après la différence
ok tout est parfait
merci merci beaucoup
merci au revoir
après une semaine passée ici je saisis
mieux la complexité du traitement des
déchets nucléaires j'ai découvert des
métiers que je ne soupçonnais pas entre
secret industriel et secret défense je
comprends un peu mieux pourquoi ici on
se méfie des caméras même si un petit
peu plus de transparence ne ferait de
mal à personne
il est temps pour moi de repartir vers
de nouveaux horizons demain j'ai
rendez-vous avec d'autres zones d'autres
femmes aux vies peu ordinaires